you know if i'm listening to norman pure
it makes me feel rich if i'm listening
to you know this this mcu this rap kid
on here talking about i don't feel rich
i feel like damn i feel broke as [ __ ]
you know just gotta just that in the
third i don't got that you know what i
mean i'd rather just listen to something
that you know just a little bit more you
know soundscape you know heavy bass uh
tempo going crazy you know what i mean
something that you can just relax your
mind to because you really sit down and
listen to these guys man you can feel
like you're missing out on all the good
things in life rap shouldn't really be
like that man right right right you
shouldn't have to listen to rap and feel
like you're missing out
on life you should be able to listen to
rap and feel like
you know like like okay this is where i
want to be but rap now makes you feel
like you're not where you want to be and
you made a mistake and i need to do what
you do it's been like that for a while